hallo leute heute stellen wir euch
wieder ein neues präfix aus der
deutschen sprache vor
und diesmal ist es das präfix aus hört
ihr am anfang von vielen deutschen
wörtern zum beispiel die ausfahrt
ausmachen ausgehen aus hat einige
bestimmte bedeutungen die ihr immer
wieder findet es kann aber auch
unterschiedliche bedeutungen haben die
bedeutung stellen wir euch gleich vor
kurz vorab alle werben mit aus sind
immer trennbare werben
das heißt dass bei einem trennbaren werk
wird immer der wortstamm konjugiert der
steht dann immer so wie jedes andere
verb an der zweiten position im satz
und dieses aus das präfix wird getrennt
in der korrigierten form und wird ans
ende des satzes gestellt hier seht ihr
mal ein paar beispiele ausmachen janisch
macht das licht aus sich ausruhen
jansrud sich nach einem anstrengenden
tag aus jetzt kommen wir zu der
bedeutung von aus es gibt zwei besonders
häufige bedeutungen
die erste ist sowas wie heraus dass
benutzt man immer wenn man etwas von
einer gruppe heraus nimmt oder wenn man
etwas aus einem raum heraus nimmt oder
einen raum verlässt im englischen würde
man das oft mit out of übersetzen und im
englischen gibt es auch ein präfix das
eine sehr ähnliche bedeutung hat nämlich
ex deswegen werden auch viele von diesen
wörtern im englischen übersetzt mit
einem wort das dann am anfang des
traffic sex hat hier sind ein paar
beispiele
der austausch der ausgang ausschließen
aussteigen in all diesen wörtern hat man
diese gleiche bedeutung etwas ist an
einem bestimmten ort oder in einer
bestimmten gruppe und dann verlässt ist
diesen ort oder diese gruppe hier sind
noch ein paar beispiele janisch hat
seinen schlüssel vergessen er hat sich
ausgesperrt
janosch will nicht mehr bei kali wohnen
er zieht aus unserer wohnung aus ich
fahre mit dem zug am berliner
hauptbahnhof steige ich aus
die zweite große bedeutung von aus ist
das etwas nicht mehr funktioniert oder
etwas nicht mehr da ist
im englischen würde man viele dieser
fälle mit oder oft übersetzen hier ein
paar beispiele ausmachen
dadurch macht das licht aus
ausgeben die amish gibt sein ganzes geld
im internet aus ausgehen
janisch ist die milch ausgegangen jetzt
muss er seinen kaffee schwarz trinken
ausfallen
aufgrund der pandemie fällt das konzert
heute leider aus übrigens wenn ihr die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln ganz
systematisch lernen möchten dann
empfehlen wir euch unsere apps sie lenkt
die app ist jetzt auch im app store und
google place tor und dort könnt ihr die
wichtigsten 6000 deutschen vokabeln
lernen und sie zb auch nach levels oder
wortarten filtern
wenn ihr zum beispiel werben mit
auslernen möchtet dann könnt ihr aus
dort eingeben und dann die werden die
ihr noch lernen möchte teuren reviews
hinzufügen und sie regelmäßig
wiederholen aus kann aber auch immer
wieder andere bedeutungen haben
wo man dieses aus eben nicht wörtlich
mit heraus oder auto oder auf übersetzen
kann
hier sind mal ein paar beispiele
ausbilden janosch bildet mich im
nahkampf ausprobieren
janisch probiert seinen neuen kopfhörer
aussehen karim acht janisch ein
kompliment zu seinem neuen style janosch
du siehst toll aus sich ausruhen jansrud
sich nach einem anstrengenden tag aus es
gibt jedoch auch wörter die mehrere
bedeutungen gleichzeitig haben und dann
muss man diese wörter tatsächlich wie
mehrere vokabeln auswendig lernen zum
beispiel das wort ausgehen
ich gehe heute abend aus janisch ist die
milch ausgegangen oder der computer geht
einfach aus es gibt auch einige werben
mit aus die eine reflexive form haben
und manchmal existiert das verb sogar
reflexiv und nicht reflexiv zum beispiel
leyen
ich leihe die kopfhörer von janosch
nicht reflexiv das gleiche wert kann ich
jedoch auch reflexiv benutzen
ich leihe mir die kopfhörer von janisch
aus in diesem fall haben beide werben
eigentlich die gleiche bedeutung
manchmal wird die bedeutung auch leicht
verändert zum beispiel austauschen
ich tausche die batterie der kamera aus
denn sie ist leer sich austauschen heißt
dass man eine unterhaltung hat janisch
und ich tauschen uns über neue ideen für
unsere videos aus manchmal haben die
reflexive und die nicht reform jedoch
auch ganz unterschiedliche bedeutungen
und die dürft ihr da nicht verwechseln
ist sie wirklich wie zwei
unterschiedliche vokabeln auswendig
lernen
hier ein beispiel janisch zieht aus
janosch zieht sich aus jetzt seid ihr
dran wir möchten euch nämlich heute um
eure themen bitten
habt ihr fragen zur deutschen grammatik
zu bestimmten vokabeln oder zu anderen
präfekten dann schreibt uns doch gerne
einen kommentar wir freuen uns immer
über eure ideen und werden dann
vielleicht demnächst auch ein video
darüber machen und wenn ihr die
wichtigsten deutschen vokabeln lernen
möchte dann empfehlen wir euch immer
noch unsere erzielen
der link ist gleich hier oben und wird
hier links eingeblendet und wir wünschen
euch jetzt einen wunderschönen abend
oder nachmittag oder morgen bis bald
[Musik]